[Music]
breaking news this Wednesday night a
private jet plummets from the sky in
Russia among those presumed dead is the
mercenary leader who staged a brief
Mutiny against the Kremlin a
controversial deal under more scrutiny
the rcmp's potential criminal
investigation into Ontario Premier Doug
Ford's Green Belt land swap
Wildfire evacuees hoping for government
compensation it definitely hasn't been a
cheap trip the help that could be on the
way
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us there
is Mystery tonight surrounding a private
plane that fell from the sky Northwest
of Moscow Russian authorities say the
founder of a mercenary group who led a
short-lived Mutiny against the Kremlin
was on the passenger list this is the
jet as it plummets to the ground there
are reports eyewitnesses saw a rocket
launch and heard two loud explosions
before the plane fell there's been no
independent confirmation that yevgeni
pregosian was on that plane two months
ago pregosian and his Wagner group
directly challenged the authority of
Russian President Vladimir Putin who
called them traitors and it's widely
believed burgosian's days were numbered
Crystal gomancing has our top story
tonight
flaming wreckage from a plane said to be
registered to the head of the mercenary
military groups
became known around the world as his
militia battled ukrainians alongside
invading Russian forces
but it was his audacious March of
Justice two months ago to the day that
had people questioning his future the
once close Ally of the Russian president
publicly criticized the military
leadership claiming his men were not
being given needed supplies for Goshen
LED his team on a mutiny to Moscow but
they didn't reach the capital a deal was
struck between him and Vladimir Putin
Jeff chadeo is with the Institute of
European Russian Eurasian studies Putin
obviously has a track record of his
opponents being poisoned being shot
falling out windows uh this is much more
dramatic uh killing but one that fits
directly with his mode of operation
burgosian's plane was traveling from
Moscow to Saint Petersburg it dropped
off the radar suddenly Wednesday evening
Russia's civilian Aviation Authority
confirmed pagosian's name was on the
passenger list it included seven people
and three crew members Russian media
reports all those on board were killed
there's not much that happens in
Russians I don't know enough to know the
answer I I there's a bunch of dominoes
that will fall in the next uh
really 24 hours and then beyond then
first of all it'll be interesting to see
what the remaining leadership of Wagner
says if doctor forces do blame the
Kremlin will their soldiers stop
fighting in Ukraine and who will be
installed as the new leader there are so
many questions that remain unanswered
not only in Europe but in Africa as well
Wagner is heavily involved in a number
of countries on that continent and those
operations are said to be incredibly
lucrative for the Kremlin Donna crystal
gemancing in London thanks the RCMP is
now exploring whether an investigation
is warranted into a land deal made by
Ontario Premier Doug Ford the province's
auditor general has already found the
deal was heavily influenced by a small
group of well-connected developers who
stand to make billions the land is part
of a protected green belt at the heart
of the greater Golden Horseshoe near
Toronto it's eight hundred and ten
thousand hectares it was created in two
thousand 5 to restrict urban sprawl and
protect Farmland wetlands and lakes
under the controversial deal nearly 3
000 hectares of land has already been
removed benefiting developers and at the
heart of the issue is whether those
developers got special treatment because
of their close relationship with Premier
Ford Colin Demello is with me from
Queens Park in Toronto Colin there have
been several inquiries into this already
before it was handed to the police give
us a sense of what they concluded well
the most significant information Donna
comes from Ontario's auditor general who
after a six-month investigation
concluded that developers were given
preferential treatment by the Ford
government when it came to the
extraction of certain lands from
Ontario's Green Belt the auditor general
determined that it was Premier Doug Ford
who kicked off The process by telling
his housing Minister specifically to
look at lands in the green belt that
could be opened up for development it
was the housing Minister's Chief of
Staff who did all of the work this
report found meeting with developers
getting packages from developers and
specific instruction on which lands to
Target that Chief of Staff has now
resigned there are questions though
about exactly what Premier Doug Ford
knew and exactly when the premier says
he didn't communicate with any
developers but Global News has already
reported in the past that the premier
held a private fundraiser at his own
home about a year ago in August of 2022
at that fundraiser there were developers
there those developers the premier said
were close personal friends and at that
fundraiser the premier was raising money
for his own daughter's wedding meaning
that money would have gone from those
developers potentially into the Ford
family pocket that is what a lot of
people here at Queen's Park in Toronto
are saying points to some kind of
evidence that Premier Doug Ford was
personally involved okay and now that
this is in the hands of the RCMP and
they're looking at a potential
investigation what could the blowback be
for Premier Ford the blowback Donna has
already started the opposition in here
say there need to be more resignations
Ontario's Integrity commissioner has
been engaged in a months-long
investigation about whether the housing
minister or any other member of the Ford
government violated ethics rules here at
Queen's Park which means there will be
much more to come not to mention
protests that the government is facing
over exactly what they have done with
the green belt the premier by the way up
backing down he says the green belt
extractions will continue all right
Colin Demello at Queen's Park in Toronto
thanks
thank you NBC rain is helping in the
fight against those wildfires
more than 20 millimeters fell overnight
in some areas where fires are raging and
that has cleared the smoke for the first
time in several days more than 25 000
people are still out of their homes
across BC some evacuation orders have
been lifted some travel restrictions
loosened but officials warn the danger
has not passed nitugartia is in West
Kelowna where a travel ban is still in
place nitu yeah Donna the ban has been
lifted in all other communities but
non-essential traffic is still being
restricted to the city of West Kelowna
for those staying in temporary
accommodations with the smoke having
cleared for the first time since The
Inferno swept through this area on
Thursday the extent of the wildfire's
destruction is being made clear
officials here say the most challenging
days are ahead as people and communities
learn of what they describe as
Monumental loss and they noted today
there will be Collective grief
filling up in Shannon Lake nearly 20
helicopters are working in the West
Kelowna area of BC's Okanagan Valley
fire officials say they were helped by
almost 22 millimeters of overnight
rainfall amazing how many homes are
still standing cleaner air means
residents like Sandra and Arden Knoll
are literally and figuratively breathing
a bit better with the smoke having
cleared they drove up to this area to
see the Mountainside they live on they
say it gives a clearer picture of the
work firefighters did to save about 3
000 houses all these homes are still
here but you can what they did is
amazing the Knolls say they were
traveling back from Saskatchewan when
Flames approached their neighborhood
unfortunately we didn't get back to our
house
before we were evacuated
but our house is still there for now
they're living out of a camper like this
family in Kelowna anxious to get home
Kirsten Furby says her family lived out
of a camper until they were assigned a
hotel room on Tuesday after leaving home
on Friday capturing these images of how
close the Flames were they're like be
prepared to evacuate immediately do you
have any official confirmation about
whether your home is still standing no
we don't yet we can see the hill behind
our house and it's not burnt Regional
officials say evacuees need an
unprecedented level of support and the
emergency Support Services have had a
difficult time keeping up we've had
large shipments almost daily coming in
from Vancouver
as volunteers like this group are
working to help fill the gaps with
donated supplies for evacuees and this
box of care packages being taken
straight to the fire department thank
you very much it's going to be very hard
for us as a community to come out of
this it's emotional for sure it's a
traumatic event as families facing
uncertainty about their homes find
comfort in knowing no human lives have
been lost in this fire and their loved
ones are safe officials say no homes
were lost in the last 24 hours but they
have assessed a new total of 84 West
Kelowna and West Bank First Nation
properties damaged with nearly 200 in
the greater area and with hundreds of
people still out of their houses they
say there's still a lot more work to be
done before more people can return home
Donna all right me too thanks
in the Northwest Territories wildfires
near Yellowknife Hay River and Fort
Smith are said to be at Bay but
thousands of evacuees are not being
allowed home and might not be able to
return for weeks as Jeff Semple reports
that's raising questions about support
for those living hundreds of kilometers
away from home
30 000 residents of the Northwest
Territories left last week in a hurry
the trip unexpected and expensive nice
to see you guys nice to see you
see you Laura digness and her husband
made the 20-hour drive with their three
young children two dogs and her
stepmother and it was pretty long we
ended up having to take two vehicles our
baby threw up everywhere their vehicles
broke down twice and needed new tires
they've already spent almost five
thousand dollars it definitely hasn't
been a cheap trip that we weren't
expecting evacuees who followed the
order and made the long drive from
Yellowknife into Alberta are spending
hundreds if not thousands of dollars on
lodging Fuel and food and are now left
wondering whether those costs will be
covered the territorial government said
this week those who left on evacuation
flights will be flown back once it's
safe but evacuees who drove could be on
the hook for their own travel costs
that news was not well received by
evacuees like this couple you didn't
request you ordered
yeah right there's a big difference yeah
yeah see you in court right
can evacuees expect to receive any
compensation for their travel costs you
know I
I want to see a cautious yes today the
territorial government sought to clarify
there will be Financial supports to
ensure everyone can get home
reimbursements for other travel costs
will be decided within days 65 of the
population is no longer in its territory
it's it's extreme and that has a number
of impacts and we're going to put some
more programs out reflective of that the
Deputy Prime Minister hinted that
Federal help is also coming we're very
happy to work with the government with
the leadership of the Northwest
Territories on what might be some
extraordinary expenses most standard
home insurance policies also cover
forced evacuations the Insurance Bureau
of Canada says expenses from extreme
weather have skyrocketed over the past
two decades make sure you review your
insurance policy know what coverage you
have this summer offering a hard lesson
on the growing costs of climate change
Jeff Temple Global News high level
Alberta
when a wildfire or another natural
disaster hits it's an emotional and
financial roller coaster for everyone
involved the effects can have long
lasting implications experts say
addressing mental health must be part of
the response
my hope that you know between things
like Crisis lines or care to speak
um that that people are able to take
advantage of getting emotional support
after what are some really difficult
professional and personal days right now
if you or someone you know is
experiencing a mental health crisis
after being affected by wildfires a
toll-free number is available you can
call 1-866-585-0445
Ontario psychologist and author Jordan
Peterson has lost a legal fight and must
undergo social media training and
Ontario Court upheld an order from the
College of psychologists of Ontario that
Peterson take a coaching course on
professionalism in public statements the
ruling followed several complaints about
his online commentary including
polarizing remarks directed at liberal
politicians a plus size model and
transgender actor Elliot page the
college determined Peterson's statements
could amount to professional misconduct
if Peterson fails to comply he could
lose his license to practice
India is on the moon tonight coming up
the giant leap forward in its Space
Program
[Music]
that is one giant leap for India it is
now the first country to land a
spacecraft on the moon's South Pole a
mysterious place that has long been of
interest to space agencies and
scientists the young man probe touchdown
early this morning Eric Sorensen
explains what it's looking for and what
it could mean for establishing long-term
settlements on the moon
chandrayan 3 circled for days finally a
safe landing spot on the harsh terrain
of the moon's South Pole
for India a nation outside the great
powers in space a breakthrough this
sucks says
belongs to
all of humanity India will be the first
to explore close up a region that every
space Nation wants to know more about
the South Pole where water in Ice opens
new possibilities for humans to live and
develop resources on other planets the
data shows us that there is water ice
there now if we want to have humans on
the surface of the Moon if we want to be
able to use those resources to go
further to you know use the moon as a
stepping stone to get to Mars there have
been more than 140 missions from the
Earth to the Moon some have orbited some
have crashed into it others have landed
safely the most famous the six Apollo
missions when 12 humans actually walked
on the moon half a century ago the U.S
and the Soviet Union were the first to
achieve soft Landings on the lunar
surface more recently on The Far Side of
the Moon China put a Lander and a Rover
on the lunar surface in 2019 and now
India the fourth country with a soft
landing at the South Pole a Rover and
Lander that can operate for two weeks
India's efforts to get their equipment
on the ground to be able to be something
of a flagship if you will to the
International Community
it means the Space Race will be more
competitive even after Russia's Luna 25
crashed on the moon this month a top
Russian official was blunt
saying Commercial and Military
advantages will be exploited in space as
the stakes increase so will the
potential for conflict I
for now India is celebrating its success
with smaller cheaper Rockets India is
promising scientific cooperation with
other countries it's also becoming a new
international power in space Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
still ahead Donald Trump prepares to
surrender to authorities in Georgia
in the U.S former president Donald Trump
is expected to turn himself into
authorities in Georgia tomorrow in the
indictment Trump is accused of being the
head of a criminal Enterprise that was
part of a broad conspiracy to overturn
his 2020 electoral defeat in that state
and Trump's former lawyer Rudy Giuliani
surrendered today Jackson prosco
explains what it all means
past the guard house and behind razor
wire Donald Trump will once again make
history as he surrenders for arrest at
Atlanta's notorious Fulton County Jail
Sheriff labad has indicated that he is
looking to treat all the dependents the
same as everybody else the former
president's time inside will be brief he
will be fingerprinted photographed and
assigned an inmate number then released
on two hundred thousand dollars bond
with strict conditions he can't discuss
the case with Witnesses or co-defendants
he can't make threats against them
either you do not have to incriminate
yourself and I think that this is a
great time when Mr Trump should should
more than likely exercise that silence
this is a racketeering case involving
some of the biggest names in Trump's
orbit alleged co-conspirators include
former white house chief of staff Mark
Meadows and former Trump lawyer Rudy
Giuliani who surrendered Wednesday this
is a
the salt on our Constitution that Fanny
Willis will go down in American history
as having conducted one of the worst
attacks on the American Constitution
ever when this case was dismissed
prosecutors are hoping some of the
defendants will plead out and flip
before trial while Trump's team is
trying to delay hoping to move the case
from state to federal courts I think
that this thing is going to go on
possibly for years there's going to be
so many appeals from both sides
smack in the middle of it all is another
presidential campaign one where a man
facing multiple state and federal
indictments is still the leading
Republican candidate
Trump is carefully choreographing his
surrender for maximum media exposure
he's turning himself in the day after
the first Republican candidates debate
which he's skipping all but guaranteeing
that Republican voters spend the next 48
hours talking about nothing but the
arrest of the party's most popular
candidate
Jackson prosco Global News Atlanta
here Canada is this squirrel munching on
a pine cone in Winnipeg Manitoba we'd
love to see your Canada please email it
to viewers at globalnational.com and
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow bye-bye
foreign
[Music]